le monde court à sa perte
le drapeau de l'empiré flotte dans toute
la galaxie
on peut vous enlever les menottes
finissons-en s'il vous plaît on a une
mission a confié
une arme décisive est sur le point
d'être testé
nos sages sur ce que c'est et comment la
détruire
si c'est vraiment ça que tu fais je veux
participer
d'accord
il ya longtemps que je recrute pour la
rébellion ils ont tout détruit
je me bats contre leur pire maintenant
je ne crains rien
août est telle que le veut la force
le capitaine dis que tu es une amie je
ne vais pas de tuer merci
on n'a pas beaucoup de temps
chaque jour ils se renforcent
il ya 90 à dire que 6 % de probabilités
pour que ça échoue
il a de bonnes intentions
c'est l'occasion pour nous
inverser le cours des choses
vous êtes avec moi
jusqu'au bout
le wali
oui
m
wind une grotte de secours est
donc
claudine fondamentale
que dire soit hélas
à effet l'afrique
temps frais
et mezouar
les agents
mais cru aux cages à toi
il boite mail